Humans consume many drugs for the psychoactive effects that they have on us.
Here we're going to discuss drugs that are potentially abused, as opposed to
drugs that are used as medicines, such as something for high blood pressure.
Some have argued that humans have a basic need to cope with their daily lives,
and that some people do so by using drugs. There are four main reasons why
people use drugs. The first is for recreational purposes. Here an individual
may use a drug to experiment or to have fun. Another reason is for social
purposes. Here an individual may take a drug because it makes them feel like
they can interact better and socialize, or they may take it for peer pressure
purposes.